I'm 52 tape ta PE I'd also like to
remind our guests here today that if you
have any questions for our guests and I
certainly trust that you will please
write them on the cards that are
provided at the table for you and pass
them up to the head table I will ask as
many as time allows I like now to
introduce our head table guess and asked
him to please stand briefly when their
names are read I also asked her audience
with Hall hold any applause until after
I've read all of the names starting on
my left is thomas webb of the Wichita
Eagle next to him is chip Cruz the style
editor of The Washington Post next is
Lisa keen of the Washington Blade extra
her is John soda green the assistant
publisher of King Publishing Group and
chairman of the national press clubs
morning news maker committee next to him
is Judy Gruber of wgm s FM radio next is
Lawrence Wilker managing director of the
Kennedy Senator for the Performing Arts
skipping over our speaker for a minute I
have Michael Mainwaring a member of the
national press club board of governors
next is mr. Gordon tyndale cultural
counselor of the British Embassy next is
Gordon Smith the member of the National
Press Club speakers committee who
arranged today's luncheon next is Ruth
Kaplan director of public affairs of the
national gallery of art and finally
happy steen theater critic The
Washington Times and panelists with Weta
TVs around town
our guest today is Sir Ian McKellen the
British actor who wears the mantle of
one of the world's leading interpreters
of Shakespeare the air to Sir Laurence
Olivier he is now performing as Richard
Duke of Gloucester in Richard the third
at Washington's Kennedy Center in it he
has transformed the role of the
malevolent King into a dark fascist
allegory the show which has been lauded
from Tokyo to Prague goes from here to
Denver San Francisco Los Angeles and st.
Paul Minnesota among his many awards and
honors or two that stand out for him
first he was knighted by Queen Elizabeth
in 1991 in honor of his long and
distinguished career in the theater and
second on jun 25th the human rights
campaign fund the nation's largest
lesbian and gay organization created the
McKellen award that it will give
annually to a prominent member of the
performing arts profession who has
significantly advanced that cause he
commented that among all his awards
quote I will treasure this one more than
any other he commented since taking a
leadership role in the gay rights
movement for years ago sir ian has
campaigned against the British law
passed under Prime Minister Margaret
Thatcher's regime that forbids local
governments from promoting homosexuality
Sir Ian visited the press club in on a
previous occasion while he was appearing
at the National Theatre in a one-man
show entitled Ian McKellen acting
Shakespeare the club's entertainment &
arts committee had purchased group
tickets and some members recall being
summoned by the actor to take part in a
scene from Shakespeare on the stage of
the national now I know our members and
their acting abilities so that must have
been a sight to see but after his talk
today he will probably make thespians of
us all ladies and gentlemen please join
me in welcoming Sir Ian McKellen
come to mommy
what I feel fine is now what am I going
to say that's the thing I've been
looking forward to this event so much
and I'm for so long ever since it was
organized and I'm only upset that just
24 hours ago I should have been
strutting down by this debilitating
complaint which means that I'm shaking
and I can't think straight so you'll
bear with me and get your questions up
here as quickly as possible because it's
much easier to respond to questions and
the impetus of questions and it is to go
through the whole spiel again and that's
what it's begun to feel like when I'm
talking to the press I've talked to a
great many people since I got to the
United States and they all want to know
about the same things but not always in
the same proportion and and so I would
like to tailor whatever I say according
to you rather than to some notion of
what you ought to be interested in
before I stop complaining about being
ill and let no one worried this is live
television and i will be appearing
tonight as Richard the third and the
Kennedy Center as I did last night
because we talked about dr. theater I
don't have you ever heard of doctors
they'd have you maybe there's dr.
newspaper for all I know but it's it is
absolutely amazing that in a state of
health which means that you you cannot
dress yourself that you haven't really
got the energy to work out while the
other person is saying to you in the
dressing room where you certainly can't
eat when all your fancy is dying
Franklin oh and yet somehow I can go out
on stage and give I think a reasonable
interpretation and performance of
Richard the third which is the longest
part in Shakespeare and has an awful lot
of legs an awful lot of demands on an
act of physical emotional and vocal I
don't know how it's done and I'm just
glad to be an actor for that reason
alone because it shows one that one is
never really perhaps as if ill as one
thinks and these little diseases that
can be dealt with by my pillar on which
is what's happening to me nice so let's
forget all that and that let me tell you
what I've been doing since I've I was
last with you I've been around the
states with acting Shakespeare and I
ended up in San Francisco where I
renewed acquaintance with Armistead
Maupin the wonderful author of tales of
the city and the five subsequent volumes
that sequel and his lover Terry Anderson
and they very gently over two or three
evenings responded to my inquiries about
what it was like to be a gay man and a
gay man was such an open and amount of
Famers Armistead Maupin has got all was
required to speak on it and always
required to have a view on it always
required to to know what's happening in
the AIDS world and together they began
to nudge me towards becoming what they
are which is a representative for a lot
of people who are not in the happy
position of coming out which is the
majority of people majority of lesbians
i guess i would suspect in this country
as it is in mind because there is so
much a discrimination are built into not
just then the fabric of life it but
built into the laws that gay men and
lesbians often feel it's easier and
better for them if they keep quiet about
it and that's what they're taught to do
from the very early age after all it
took me till I was 49 to come out and
that's what happened when I went back to
England and I came out over the issue
which i won't go into now because it's
all rather tedious and
except it's an example of Thatcher going
wrong she really thought you see that in
taking on local governments and that's
basically what the argument was about it
was a from a centralizing prime minister
who didn't approve of the left-wing
elected representatives in local
government who was spending very minimal
funds on gay health plans and that sort
of thing she encapsulated all this in
the memorable words promotion of
homosexuality as if sexuality was
something that you could promote except
no one's ever come forward to give a
single reason why that should be true
and I but there is this notion going
around that somehow gays are
proselytizing and want to convert
everyone to their way of life there
enough gays without bothering with the
rest of you know and
it's just a question of identifying each
other and we're encouraged we're
encouraged by the rest of you to keep
quiet you see that's the problem anyway
Thatcher Thatcher was trying to stop the
promotion of homosexuality and what did
she do with this mean-spirited our
little law section 28 of the local
government act she persuaded people like
me and people like Michael Cashman and
people like John Schlesinger and cameron
mackintosh to come out of the closet
where they lived all their adult life
and say they didn't approve and that
there was a point of issue here which
personally affected us all very deeply
and what has happened as a result of
that is that groups like the stonewall
group of course named after the events
in Greenwich Village all those years ago
but taking a different line to trying to
change laws by and lobbying directly
Parliament in Europe as well as in
Westminster all this activity the fact
that you can't pick up a copy of the
independent newspaper these days the new
very successful broadsheet a number
without raising regularly news stories
from the gay point of view not
necessarily written by a gay man or a
lesbian but presenting the gay point of
view there is a regular program on the
independence TV channel which is made by
a group of lesbians there was quite
recently recently on bbc2 all evening
long material that was a thought to be
appropriate and would be enjoyed by
lesbians and gays presenting that point
of view of the world and I'm happy to
say that the only member of parliament
who is out who is not ashamed to say
that he's gay increased his majority
against all the trends he's a leper man
by over 10,000 votes so it's no longer
unpopular to be gay and in the public
life and that's my experience too and
it's just a ride pleasure to me the
thatch I got it absolutely wrong she
thought she was going to take the gavel
and bang us on the head and to send us
back into the nursery
and what happened is we walked out of
the nest when we bang the door behind
them back behind ourselves and we're now
in the real world and it's she who's
retired and not ask and the last thing
she did would you believe it the last
thing she did was to give me a
knighthood I was in Paris I was in Paris
on tour with Richard the third and at
that time King Lear as well watching the
Mary site of 10 Downing Street and
advocate infusion thanks to CNN i think
it was being shown on on european
television and in between Christ and
black coffee the phone rang and a voice
said this is Miss sludge of 10 Downing
Street could I speak to Ian McKellen and
eyes immediately knew as one of my
friends from the company calling me up
and I said mister why didn't you get
right down here and get into bed with
him you can watch television together
she said this is no moment for joking
mr. McKellen we've got a lot going on
here today I said to tell me you really
are and Dan street and she gave me the
number and I called it back and that was
how i learned that mrs. Thatcher had it
in mind to recommend to the Queen that
she should appoint me a knight bachelor
and it was the last thing I think she
ever did as Prime Minister because I say
the next shot of her was coming out of
Dentistry crying and waving
some friends in the gay movement thought
it was in politic of me to accept a
knighthood they thought it was a sign
that I had somehow succumbed to the
establishment of which I've long been
apart and that my coming-out was thrown
into jeopardy as a point of principle
and that now that I was knighted I would
no longer even though the minimal level
be joining in with the other activists
who had got to know over the last two
years I was not fool enough as I was not
so much of a fool not to inquire of
friends what they thought about me
accepting a knighthood and we all agreed
that it was it was a very useful weapon
to have someone so openly pro-gay rights
and therefore anti-government to have a
knighthood and I know you don't have
them here but they're very useful
weapons in England and doors really do
open when you knock on them and the
gentleman it's usually a gentleman on
the other side of the desk actually gets
up and shakes your hand and you can have
a decent conversation with them and
that's how I came to meet John Major I
think I can talk about that if you want
me to so what's happened well labour
lost the election that's what happened
the Stonewall group had lobbied all
three main parties and had very much in
hand A+ legislation had labor become the
majority government and and when they
failed to do that one one's heart sank
to think that it was the children of
Thatcher who were going to be in charge
of our destinies and we're going to be
able to tell us whether it was legal for
us to make love whether it was going to
be legal for us to hold hands in public
whether it's going to be legal for us to
declare our love for each other in some
sort of contract whether it was going to
be legal to complain about dismissal
from a job as a school teacher because
one was gay or lesbian there is
I must be up to miss Kate optimistic a
group of people within the Westminster
Parliament from all parties who are as
impatient as lesbians and gays are to
change the legislation and already we've
managed even even under the tail end of
thatcherism to get rid of the anomaly of
two islands and amongst the British
Isles both of which where it was illegal
to be homosexual or to make love to
someone of your own sex one of these
animals called the isle of jersey and
the other i er aunty was called the Isle
of Man
but that was assigned to me and it was
also assigned when major apparently off
his own bat announced just but just over
a year ago that in future to be gay and
lesbian would no longer be at
disadvantage for anyone going up the
ladder in the Secret Service or the
Diplomatic Service that was a very good
sign we are just a little bit doubtful
whether that instruction is being
followed through there was whilst I've
been away in America a very hopeful sign
that the armed forces are going to
really again look at their ludicrous
rules which they're afraid share only
with your country anything with no other
country and later where they don't have
problems with lesbians and gays serving
amongst them and but I think the debate
is going to happen in the Commons quite
soon and I think also there's going to
be a debate on the age of consent which
throughout the United Kingdom is 16 for
boys and girls doing it together is 21
for men doing it together and lesbians
don't have any instruction as to what
they should do in or out of there and
that's why I like to send these
occasions i'm thinking of becoming a
lesbian
it's been wonderful to meet up here with
I mean not just Washington DC but but
New York City with the people who are
showing the rest of the world the way
there are great advances of course in
Europe not yet in Eastern Europe
lesbians gays have a perception how time
but the experience that you have and and
the accepted principle that there are
some rights which belonged to all men
and women and a constitution which
enshrines those rights is something
quite alien to to the British Way of
life and it's I think perhaps more
difficult for us to make our point we do
have one advantage over this country is
that ours is a very small country and we
do bump into each other John Major
actually comes to the National Theatre
and it was as a result of him seeing a
play there that I had supper with him
and then we arranged to meet at Downing
Street it it's possible to feel that you
are all in the same village in London
and that special interests do cross over
which I guess isn't always true in the
metropolitan areas here i would like to
said something about the nea the
National Endowment for the Arts and I'll
just say briefly in case anybody asks a
question about it I'm appalled that
there should be any suggestion that the
very minor complaints against the
inspiriting and and a huge achievement
of that institution over the last 17
years should be put in jeopardy by a
pebble frankly thrown out the windows of
a palace you don't dismantle an
institution like the NEA because a very
very small group of people who have
another agenda all together pretend that
there they are dissatisfied with the NEA
as a whole
and and I say that with an enormous
amount of feeling because throughout my
career in my own country I have been a
product of subsidized theater whether it
was in the regions on tour or settling
down in a city somewhere where there was
a local theater all working at the
national theatre or working for the
Royal Shakespeare Company or touring
abroad I am employed by the nation via
the Arts Council of great britain which
is our equivalent of your nea and it
means i don't earn that much money but
i'm very proud to be allowed on occasion
to represent my country and and what's
it as the people wants to encourage the
british people do like the theater you
know more of us go to the theater each
year then go and see a game of
association football which is out which
is our national sport is an astonishing
figure you go to the national theatre
it's very difficult to get tickets
whether the plays are old on you whether
they're English American and whoever's
in them and there is a thriving a
thriving respect for the Arts and it
would be very stupid governments I think
that ever decided to remove the grant
from from the arts generally as seems to
be being proposed in your country but
I'm a foreigner and I've no right to
interfere but it's difficult not to when
you care as much as I do and perhaps I
can just mention that the other
wonderful thing about coming to make at
this time is that I've met only in print
and perhaps fallen in love with the
commander Margaretta camera my Amazon
who is going to having been dismissed
from the Armed Forces for being lesbian
or identifying a surface lesbian is now
prepared against her whole experience to
take on the army and prove that they
have abused her rights there will not be
an easy thing for her to do and I'm full
of admiration for her and anybody else
in the in the gay rights world who is
standing up so publicly
play the question yep okay I appreciate
that the first question is a sharp-eyed
first in the audience who noted that you
were wearing for a radio audience it's a
red ribbon in the chevron oh yeah they
want to know what is the significance of
the Red River this signifies that I am
aware of aids and it's it's warm on
public occasions by I think principally
people in show business but not
exclusively I noticed them on the sports
awards the other night on on national
television are all the recipients and
all the all the hosts were wearing them
it hasn't quite caught on yet in England
and I think it's just a reminder to
people at the other end of a television
who may not be because they're living
away from metropolitan areas may not be
as intimate with the what's happening in
aids and how it is spreading so
appallingly into the heterosexual
community and this is just to remind you
to think about it and perhaps do
something about it this questioner wants
to know how do you feel regarding your
title as Sir Laurence Olivier's air
which I happen to kiss me now that's it
that's an old question wish you had when
Kenneth Branagh was here I suspect
you know we're all sought to be Lance
Olivia said allari died you know quite a
long time ago aged 84 I'd much rather
someone was thought to be the next year
in mcallen in your performance you
perform Sir Richard as a man without a
use of it one arm and you are able to
put on a glove with only one arm this
questioner wants to know how in the
world did you ever learn to put that
glove on with one hand and how long did
it take you you may not realize but
performances change in in detail and in
grand design often over a long period
been doing this production now for over
two years in a variety of different
sorts of theaters and in different
countries and it wasn't until the first
week in Brooklyn only am i right here
John was it in Brooklyn it was in
Brooklyn that one day I was trying to
get the glove on with one hand because
that's what I have to try and do and I
normally just yank it down in my teeth
and if that's not work because it's a
lined glove and if I'm sweating the
whole thing sticks together in his
ludicrous all right I push it on behind
my back like that that night it just
went on and I discovered in the middle
performs how to do it you you put the
glove on as far as you can then you
throw it away from you and something
about it that sends it back onto your
hand and critics pick on this moment as
either being the the summary what is
brilliant about the performance oh of
course the other forget acting I think
you just learned a new principle of
physics in the Nobel Committee will be
talking to you you are familiar with
both New York and Washington audiences
how do you perceive the difference if so
can you characterize it well New York is
a very individual and it would
a you know to compare Washington with
New York would be the same as comparing
I suspect San Francisco with new york
new york is just a bit different and i
think i would have to say that if one's
looking for enthusiasm at the end of a
performance and indeed during it it was
one's listening out for those intakes of
breath or those hoops of delight which I
can't imitate which young Americans show
their appreciation me and clapping and
cheering and stamping and standing up
then I'm New York wins wins and there
are only challenge really bad my
experience the audiences in in Israel
and possibly in belfast northern ireland
and i think in the latter two cases it's
because they are so pleased that you
visited them and gone well you know and
both those communities you can feel very
cut off if you're just an ordinary
citizen and and many people in israel
and Bofur and long round like the arts
and when artists go they get a great
welcome but i have thought a lot about
what it is about New York and theater
and isn't it to do with the fact that
New York actually isn't the capital of
the nation in the way that London which
is where most theater is in London is
the capital of the United Kingdom and so
there is nothing to theater is allowed
to be the most important thing in New
York the New York Times has actually
given its name to the area where the
theater gets put on Times Square and and
the the person who writes that review in
the New York Times is somehow and very
central to what it is to be a New Yorker
and i think is often leaned on by other
New Yorkers rich and poor who want to
get him to say what they want him to say
theater expresses the spirit of that
city in a way that it is never going to
do here because you've got politics here
and
that's my glass on New York in acting
Shakespeare you asked the audience name
all 37 of Shakespeare's plays don't
worry I won't ask you to name all 37
them I would be putting you on the spot
which of Shakespeare's plays do you feel
is unfairly ignored in comparison with
the others and why which do you feel is
somewhat over performed in what in 25
words or less yeah I suppose there's
some sense to that question
in England of course we see most of the
players an awful lot at the time but you
have a very very many Shakespeare
Festival's across the united states and
and i haven't never looked through that
to check their repertoires to see which
are the most popular players I do think
perhaps people should lay off as you
like it and lay off my favorite player
Twelfth Night because they always get it
wrong Shakespeare wrote the leading part
in that player to be played by a boy or
a man or a male and until someone who
does it they're not going to Reese
release the very complex sexuality of
that play of course when we do that God
knows what the people who attacked the
NEA are going to complain about Hamlet I
think gets done too often and I would I
would I would say perhaps all the
players get to done too often unless
they're going to be done with as much
good intentions as possible it isn't
easy to do Shakespeare and one doesn't
always bring it off but those of us who
spend an awful lot of time doing
Shakespeare our perhaps more likely to
to to reach the desired result I I can't
think of one play that's doesn't get
done often enough perhaps I'd have to
say time in of Athens because I've never
seen it other than the obvious verse in
Shakespeare's plays what would you
consider to be the primary difference
between Shakespearean acting and method
acting that's again might be another
question I don't
come on come on come on give me your
hand sir Gibby I handsome and early
stirrer by the Rood and how does my good
cousin silence well that's the beginning
of a very naturalistic speech which
Shakespeare wrote quite early on in his
career and the astonishing thing about
shapes but is the range of his style you
might think that it is became citizen
third that it was all regular blank
verse and there is no probes in that
play but in Henry the fourth part 1 and
2 which he wrote shortly after that
there's a lot of pros Iago which I
recently played is all pros and you can
only succeed as Yaga if you make the
words if you're making up the words as
you go along or indeed pretending to and
I guess that is some of the heart of
what it is to be what was that phrase
I've forgotten it the method yes yes the
method shake that it's much more
difficult you know to accept that the
complications of Shakespeare and so some
of it is high rhetoric some of it is
very very very complicated verse
particularly towards the end of his life
that one sometimes despaired of ever
making understandable and some of it is
absolutely normal conversation which
could have been written for a an
ultra-modern play perform for the first
time yesterday and so I think the two
disciplines overlap this questioner says
asked tell us about the London AIDS
facility you helped start it's called
the London lighthouse and it was
imagined by a very small group of people
who had had experience of death
counseling and helping people through
grieving and so on and realize that that
there was some close connection between
that and undying when south and
in 1988 there was no facility really in
anywhere in the world actually which
dealt exclusively with people who were
HIV positive or who had AIDS and the
building divide yourself up into two on
the top it's got a hospice where people
go to die and where people go to recover
because of course aids does not kill you
I think one can fairly say that in
certain doesn't kill you straight off
and there's that much argument as to as
to how long one can survive with the HIV
virus on the next floor you have the
offices which keep a large and important
institution going and also you have
counseling services there and anybody
can walk into that building with a
problem and be treated for free because
although the building was built from
public subscription it is funded in the
main by the nation through the National
Health Service but we have to raise
money for it to do all the extra things
that London lighthouse needs to do there
are of course other aids wards in the
general hospitals and and many of them
are run by the same sort of devoted
saints that run London lighthouse and
that all this is consisting in the
middle of a national health service I
think has helped the image of gay men
and lesbians because they are often
either as as the person with the disease
or the person treating the disease all
the person living with the person who's
got the DS often at the forefront of
trying to understand it and what should
be done about it in terms of treatment
and counseling and looking for a cure
and that gay men are openly working with
government institutions as probably
helped the general public's awareness
that gays and lesbians are may be
treated as outcasts but they don't
usually behave like them
I'd like to ask a question my own a
couple weeks ago when I was traveling
with Dan Quayle I after stopping he was
speaking at the Southern Baptist in
Indianapolis on his family values speech
in which he made some disparaging
references about homosexual excusing
homosexuality yeah on the plane after
that I asked him do you believe that
homosexuality has a biological cause or
is it a voluntary lifestyle and without
a beat he said it was a voluntary
lifestyle do you agree with that no no
no he betrays his ignorance on this you
every time he opens his mouth on it it's
a you know people argue about what makes
somebody gay but with no more enthusiasm
them you argue about what makes you
straight you know I think that's a very
very silly point of view and perhaps I
should elaborate on it because maybe a
lot of people watching or listening tend
towards that point of view that mr.
Crowe was expressed I don't think it's
healthy when politicians get involved in
morality and that said one has to take
them seriously when they speak because
they get an awful lot of attention and
they intend to get an awful lot of votes
out of what they say but everything that
he said about being gay just isn't
doesn't run in accord with what I know
about it and I think that's true of most
major politicians in this country and in
my own country they don't think about it
and the people who are paid to think but
people who are paid to understand the
world that they live in even those parts
of the world that they don't go to and
don't visit and don't have much sympathy
with that then should come out with an
assumption about someone's life which
allows them then to be derogatory in all
sorts of ways i think is a shameful
behavior
you
how would you contrast the situation of
gay and lesbian people in Britain
without gays and lesbians in the united
states are there any major differences
between the two countries and legal
sanctions against gays public acceptance
etc it depends where you are if you're
in the United Kingdom the laws on the
whole are the same wherever you are the
restrictions are the same if you're in
the United States you will be affected
by them not just the federal law of the
state law and I'm not familiar enough
with those differences to to explain
them to you but it's certainly true that
in metropolitan areas like San Francisco
and New York City there is an
understanding about what it is to be go
which is allowed lesbians and gays to
really advance their rights and persuade
politicians that laws have local laws
have to be changed but of course I'm
well aware than other areas of the
country that's that's not true so I
suppose we're slightly better off in
England or Scotland or Wales you know
where you are you're illegal all the
time pretty well but it as I say that
makes it perhaps a little bit easier for
a national campaign in the United
Kingdom to begin to take off because
that's what you have to do there are
there are no there are no local laws
which apply to homosexuality with the
exception of this dreadful section 28
which was just natural cast but that of
course was our central government
control over local authorities this
questioner wants to know how do you feel
about outing what political impact in
this hat
it's difficult to talk about this except
to another gay man or a lesbian because
we know what it's about and we know how
important it is to us to complete that
process or to imagine a time and we were
completed people imagination you know do
we'll go to the graves without ever
saying that they're gay even though
they've led a gay lifestyle that's what
makes it so easy for dan quayle to
misunderstand the situation but um
what's the question I don't know that
how do we aren't accounting us but if
we're then talking about this very
delicate process of coming out this
maturing process it isn't like getting
it doesn't like getting an award you
know it's not like it's not like getting
a a scroll of honour that can feel like
that it's so much more than that it's
about honesty it's about your
self-awareness it's about your saying to
the rest of the world here i am and take
me as you find me as I take you and can
we now get on with living together as
much or as little as we want to so you
can't have that process done on your
behalf it doesn't make sense and the
argument often given that that young
people in gays and lesbians need role
models and therefore it's appropriate to
bring people out of the closet against
their will they're the last people to be
decent role models because they're not
honest about themselves and so I don't I
don't take that argument the only time I
I do agree with with with outing is in a
case of hypocrisy in high places and by
high places I would I would I mean
politics if there is a gay man or a
lesbian who is undeclared has not
declared themselves and who wittingly
helps to pass legislation which will not
affect them but he that he or she knows
will affect less fortunate lesbians and
gays who don't live in
a capital city and don't get a decent
wage and are surrounded by bigots in a
way that people in and the Capitol Hill
on are not not surrounded by them there
are some but not surrounded by then I
think that persons should be outed
because they've they're breaking
standards which are intolerable in in
public and public life but on the whole
I don't approve abouting it's much more
personal process and my answer to outing
is talk to people about outing
themselves that's the point and I'm very
grateful that our mustard and Terry did
it to me if you could go back 20 years
would you come out as a gay in your 20s
would I do it now if i'm a 29 I
sometimes look back at my early
photographs would you ever do this and
think what did I miss out on your night
I look so cute in their bed
I don't know no I couldn't have come out
20 years ago I'm no could most of my
friends there was no pressure on us to
do it we thought that we thought the
important issues in the world were
nuclear weapons and perhaps we were
right we thought the important issues
were women's rights I mean thought the
important issues were capital punishment
and we fought for those and we march for
those and we wrote letters about them
and I remember thinking when all those
issues had reasonably been resolved I
remember saying defenders there's
nothing less left to fight for and I was
a gay man in the closet I didn't know
that much about myself it's very hard
being gay and it's very hard to come out
if you're of my generation and I
couldn't have done it 20 years ago would
I do it if I were now 20 years younger
than than I am today there's a
possibility because there are so many
young people at colleges and
universities who have support groups
they are from from teachers and people
of their peer group who can explain the
problems and bring families and
individuals to terms with them and maybe
if I were lucky enough to bump into such
groups to pick up that book which which
I could make a connection yes I would be
brave enough to come out at the age of
33 or rather than 53 this questionnaire
says speak to us of John Major the
pluses the minuses yes um well I suppose
you want to know what he's like and
because you can guess about and country
from from the your own reports and other
people's reports in newspapers he's a
good listener and on this particular
issue he said he was ignorant about it
as most straight men are but he unlike
most statement he wanted to find out
more about it because he was aware that
they were concerned and if he could help
he was perfectly prepared to do so
within his
odd thing for a prime minister said but
prime minister to say but that's how he
felt it he listened to me for 40 minutes
and we have seen each other once since I
think he's exactly what you see him at
he doesn't die as hair he hasn't had a
facelift he really needs those glasses
he buys his suits at Marks and Spencer
you can sort of tell but it doesn't
matter what I'm dying to find out is
whether he can put his glove on with one
hand I getting back some Shakespearean
acting questions could Richard the third
be played sympathetically Allah the
Ricardian or musty be played as a
malevolent our the tutors what a bit of
both really um I don't think it's true
that the play is simply written on
behalf of the queen of the time Queen
Elizabeth the first whose grandfather
had killed which of the third in battle
I don't think it's just propaganda
because there is too much about Richard
which is explained and he is not but the
academic critics of so often dismissed
him as just evil incarnate which is
probably what the tutor official line
was but on the matter of whether you
could play him as he was in real life no
you couldn't I I once made the mistake
of that when i was playing TE Lawrence
on British television played by Terence
Rattigan called Ross about Lance of
Arabia and since that played been
written there were a number of very
interesting biographies come out which
cast a new light on the man's
personality and I tried to incorporate
this guess what it's all about being gay
and I couldn't incorporate it because
terms Ratigan or low gay himself was
absolutely adamantly not going to reveal
that and in his play even when he was
writing about a man who was probably
Gabe so so I learnt on that occasion and
many others you have to do the script as
it's written and your job really as an
actor is to be at the service of the
script and not at the service of some
idea which is beyond the script and not
what they offer intent what effect has
the Thatcher government arts budget cuts
had on the British theatre I must be
careful here because I suspect I haven't
actually been any cuts there haven't
been the sort of increases we would have
liked I think that's more point and
there is a look at the Arts Council now
taking place within government
particularly by David Mellor who is the
new minister of the Arts the first time
we've had a minister the arts actually
in the cabinet where he may go one of
two ways he may bring a lot of money to
the arts or he may to the the major line
which on the whole is not particularly
sympathetic to the arts or sees the arts
as something which can be used for the
nation as opposed to an integral part of
the nation you know a big fireworks
displays a upper at Covent Garden
they're both lovely in their way but
then it's with the price of tickets for
coven gun that's actually not what the
people of Great Britain think of as art
because it's right it's beyond the
beyond their pocket I don't know we're
going to have to watch very very
carefully and at least we're all
confident that majors government can be
talked to and they have most of them
like going to the theater David Mellor
their new arts Minister actually at one
of his sons was actually played one of
the princes I murdered in the tire so I
have a very special relationship
for that particular Minister this
questionnaire wants to know what is the
size of theatre where you perform reach
to the third in London kennedy center
opera house is about 2,300 seats do you
find it difficult to make Shakespeare's
language heard there the the theater and
on the south bank of the Thames is the
Littleton theater it's a proscenium
theater with a picture stage and there
are nine hundred and eleven people when
it's full watching the Olivia theater is
200 people more than that in the cottage
low where I recently did Uncle Vanya
seats only 300 people it was a big shock
to me having completed Uncle Vanya to I
think almost universal acclaim and and
to have been discovering perhaps for the
first time that I knew how to act at
that level a level where I was not
projecting the performance when I was
not selecting from the performance but I
was just presenting the character as
best I could for the audience to come to
terms with in their own way as
individuals and connected and then when
we come to play Richard the third which
is an epic production and is suited to
large spaces in this very very large
theater which shows two thousand more
than the cottesloe when I did not come
value yes it's it's a cultural shock and
as for audibility some people say they
can hear perfectly and some people say
they have difficulty and I guess that's
true of most human beings that we don't
always agree and I don't know what to do
about it I speak as clearly as I can and
I'm I think generally thought to be one
of those who doesn't have a problem but
maybe I'm wrong number of questions will
know about your personal background who
was or is your mentor your teachers who
most influenced you did you attend one
of the great training academies in
London such as the royal academy of
dramatic dramatic art and country reps
in 1961 when I left Cambridge University
I was 22 years old and I'd done an awful
lot of acting not just to Cambridge 21
plays there but a lot of acting at
school before that second to school and
I've been to an awful lot of players i
felt i was ready to have a go at earning
a living at it and because i got a job
straight away i've never had any formal
training whatsoever I'm well that isn't
true because at their rod-shaped become
the end of the royal national theatre
there are people on hand to help with
that training at once or another on the
voice and on the body and on relaxation
and on fighting stage fighting and I'm
very very grateful to them all but my
style of acting and our has just
happened really and I suppose it's going
to take a book eventually to it for me
to relive the journey and there are a
number of obvious points when when I
change direction and the first was in a
production of tyrone guthrie who for all
my praise you know about the Arts
Council of great britain and and and my
slight dispraise of the MEA I should
point out that Guthrie couldn't get
anybody in the United Kingdom to build
him a theatre and he had to come to your
country to Minneapolis to for the local
people to say we believe in art so much
that we want to raise money for John
Dexter had to leave the country when he
wanted to run with it and he came to New
York City to run the Metropolitan Opera
Peter Brook had to leave England he
probably told you the other week because
it was only in Paris and Iran that that
he had the funds to put on his shows we
weren't too generous with those exiles
but Guthrie then working at Minneapolis
and I should be able to see his theta
the first time when I planned some Saint
Paul next month I he was directing
Coriolanus with me as Telus Phidias and
that he just taught me a great deal
about
daring on the stage and risking on the
stage and risking making a fool of
yourself on the stage in the hope that
you could hit the truth of complicated
characters in complicated situations and
more recently than that I work with the
director who also had strong connections
with this country because he trained
here Mike Alfred's who works almost
exclusively in the United Kingdom with
his own company but I brought him to the
National Theatre to direct the cherry
orchard and in the cottage owned a small
theater and that was thought to be a
very good production at his style of
rehearsing is to prepare the actors in
every possible way except with regard to
where they move on the stage and you
improvise that every night you say the
same words but you don't necessarily say
them in the same spirit in the same
intensity same volume you are living in
the moment and it's very close I think
to what you would take to be at the
basis of American sort of acting so it's
instant that those two giants in my life
Guthrie and and Mike Alfred's should
have worked here and learned so much
about theatre from your country okay to
related to questions here one says when
I saw your production of rich the third
I noticed no minorities in your cast
what is your view of non-traditional
casting especially in casting
Shakespeare and this one says is there a
male role in Shakespeare that you like
to see played by a woman if so which one
and why yes cesario in Twelfth Night and
I've never seen and Rosalind which i
have seen played by a man on two
occasions one of the productions that
toured the United States yes it's a
vexed question isn't it the the color of
our other actors and of course there are
many many actors throughout the
generations in the United Kingdom who
are black and
who wanted to play in all the same place
as as white actors do and why the hell
shouldn't they and that is on the whole
the policy of the National Theater and
if it weren't I didn't think I would
want to work there that said there are
some occasions when when you want the
look of a production to be more dominant
than anything else in it or autumn auto
auto contribute a strong influence and
maybe I'm not speaking on my own behalf
now maybe which had thought there were
no black people in in the thirties in
England when we've set our player
Richard the third and in the sort of in
the corridors of Westminster and that
the power card and therefore would be
inappropriate but there are actually two
actors in the company who have Indian
parents and it's it's a vexed question
and I've not quite come to terms with it
but everything about me about my really
about movers thinks that blacks should
play any part that I'm up for and if
it's a problem for the audience it'll be
a problem that will be resolved very
very quickly when you know about half an
hour after the curtain goes up that's
been my experience of seeing players
with multiple cars before asking the
last question I'd like to present you
with this certificate of appreciation
for appearing here thank you gave one to
Prince Philip maybe you can compare and
also this book the North American Indian
was wonderful and for the last question
after years as an actor do you have a
favorite piece of biting criticism that
has been directed at you by the theater
critics